if you're not doing something that
stands out and gives hiring managers a
reason to talk to you and genuinely sets
you apart from other recruiters that are
probably just as good as you at
delivering and finding candidates and
representing people then they're not
going to talk to you well we've got a
mentorship and then like almost like a
scholarship program and we have cohorts
of candidates that are trying to break
into the security industry and there's
very few people that actually have
something that's a genuinely unique
talking point whereas what we're able to
say is well if you work with us then
you're actually directly funding early
stage cyber security careers